vous savez quand j'étais jeune je
faisais jamais attention qui avait édité
tel ou tel lieu je veux dire c'est
normal après tout on s'en foutait on
achetait les jeux en fonction des
magazines ou des images sur la boîte
mais là quand je vois et c'est
franchement hasard que je vais encore
vous montrer un jeu d'electronic art
je commence vraiment à me poser des
questions sur la qualité des
programmeurs à l'époque parce qu'on
retrouve chez ce jeu exactement la même
tare génétique que chez dark castle deux
ans séparent la sortie du jeu sur amiga
et la sortie de son adaptation megadrive
on pourrait supposer que ce serait au
moins aussi bon malheureusement
electronic art va nous prouver que non
sauf soudan sorti en 1990 sur megadrive
adapté d'une version amiga un jeu qui
m'a été vivement conseillée par l'un
d'entre vous que je ne remercie pas
d'ailleurs et vous allez vite comprendre
pourquoi
[Musique]
on commence par choisir son héros vous
avez le choix entre xena et musclor mais
de toute façon les deux sont bidons
c'est exactement le même donc je vais
prendre la [ __ ] bla bla bla bla bla
on s'en fou de l'histoire c'est juste un
truc genre la presse mes couilles qui
veut reprendre son trône volé par un
magicien noir bref le truc habituel et
c'est quoi cette arnaque là elle avait
comme si soutif sur l'écran de sélection
qu'un passage les héros ne vous rappelle
rien et oui golden axe ça c'est un vrai
jeu sorti un an avant la version
megadrive de son offre selon
personnellement je trouve que la version
amiga est bien plus belle que son
équivalent megadrive il ya plus de
niveaux plus d'ennemis différents
l'animation est plus fluide les couleurs
plus sobres
même le gameplay est mieux de l'autre
côté la version megadrive des espèces de
couleurs flashy furent horrible et pour
le reste des personnages s'est animée
sur deux trams mais mais mais pour de
vrai c'est vraiment animé sur de tram
regarder le but du jeu ça alors c'est
d'avancer en tuant tout le monde et
c'est ça le problème c'est fait pour les
tb vous ne pouvez pas esquiver vous ne
pouvez pas parer tout ce que vous faites
c'est d'avancer en tapant comme des
idiots franchement où est le jeu là si
c'est pour appuyer comme un idiot sur la
même touche pendant trois heures et
finir la journée avec une tendinite je
suis désolé votants joue à craquer de
films donc pour les contrôles vous
pouvez sauter mais ça sert à rien vous
pouvez aussi faire un coup verticale à
l'épée mais
ça non plus ça sert à rien en gros vous
avez quatre coups normal verticale
accompli ou en avant selon les ennemis
faut utiliser l'un ou l'autre mais sur
ses coups il y en a en fait qu'un seul
que vous avez utilisé la plupart du
temps c'est le couac ou pis on fait la
gestion des collisions et des ebook sont
tellement puantes qu'il ya que le poids
qu'on pille qui vont mettre hors de
portée des ennemis concrètement ça veut
dire que pour tuer des ennemis la seule
solution c'est de leur casser les
couilles mais au premier sens du terme
et une brochette de boules pour la table
2 c'est très amusant pendant 10 secondes
en fait sur d'autres se danse à peu près
le seul jeu où vous commencerez déjà à
vous ennuyer avant même d'avoir fini le
premier niveau
vous savez la collision c'est ce qui
permet d'éviter dans un jeu qu ennemi
vous traversent c'est aussi ce qui
définit la taille de la hitbox qui
décide à quel moment le je considère que
vous avez pris un coup et ici dans ce
jeu je dirais pas qu'elle est buggé mais
je dirais qu'elle a été saboté c'est la
seule explication possible tu peux pas
rater un truc comme ça sans faire exprès
tu peux pas à moins qu'ils aient
programmer l'heure je ne sais pas avec
des moufles ou pendant un tremblement de
terre quoi elle va les regarder sa cause
de toi je suis hors de portée de sa
lancée il arrive quand même à empêcher
qu les conneries de jeu des fois vous
êtes en train de taper des ennemis et
puis rien ils s'en foutent
en fait je prends me doutais que lorsque
les ennemis se superposent vous ne
pouvez frapper que celui qui est au
premier plan et du coup celui qui en
arrière-plan lui peut continuer à
avancer
donc en fait sans doute de dire que la
technique ça serait qu'il faudrait
frapper en reculant tout en mettant tous
les ennemis du même côté de façon à ce
refus mer c'est juste un jeu pourri en
faire regardez donc cette séquence de
gameplay hyper enrichissante qui
démontre tout le fun incroyable qui
ressort de ce jeu
ouais modern warfare 2 fait clairement
pas le poids face à un jeu comme ça un
autre problème de la collision ça avec
ces géants en gros déjà il ya qu un seul
type de coût qui peut les toucher les
traductions si votre épée elle arrive
pas sur eux avec un angle verticale de
38 degrés c'est même pas la peine
d'essayer
super logique ensuite il faut reculer
qu'elle soit 50% de vie parce que sinon
les coûts ne marche plus de nouveau
sérieusement comment vous êtes sensé
deviner sa pour taper un gyan il faut
utiliser un coup unique parce que les
trois hommes ne marche pas déjà il faut
que ce coup unique soit porté deux fois
au contact et trois fois à deux mètres
de distance et là seulement vous pouvez
espérer que tu es habitants cogner il
aurait aussi pu dire que pour tuer un
géant il fallait boire une potion rouge
et une caution bleus à 12h gmt +1
vendredi 13 en faisant de retour sur soi
même et on tapera la combinaison abb a
baissé à start et select seraient
demandées terme temps et ça c'est que la
théorie parce que dans la pratique
non mais je rêve [ __ ] de merde c'est
pas vrai quoi mais ils veulent s pas
prochaine grève
non non je ne fais pas je me demande est
ce que vous avez déjà eu les mêmes flash
que moi en jouant à des jeux comme ça
est-ce qu'en jouant à ce genre de jeu
qui vous énerve tellement vous avez
jamais rêvé de prendre une chaise et de
tout casser chez vous
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que ça soulagerait niveau iv
il va falloir traverser un cimetière
quelle originalité
histoire de corser la difficulté les
zombies sont anciens power rangers
sauvetage est clair qu'il est une
traînée des toiles mignonne km/heure et
qu'il faut sauter pour éviter les mêmes
stratégies ou le la plus haut plus
horrible c'est quoi ce délire mais il y
en a combien j'en ai même pas avancer je
peux pas tout je peux pas tous les tuer
c'est pas possible c'est un truc de fou
et c'est impossible verte et regarder ça
seul l'aspect s'il savait fusil importe
qu'il faudrait là c'est pas une épée je
ne peux pas c'est impossible
laisse tomber allez allez fais chier
pétrole je hais ce jeu je sais même pas
pourquoi je continue à y jouer
oui les bruitages sont vraiment beau et
puissant
n'empêche qu'on regarde ça à l'époque ce
jeu était ultra violent c'est rare de
voir autant de jus de myrtille dans un
jeu quand même c'est sûr aujourd'hui
maintenant ça a l'air de rien mais
regardez quand on décapite légion quand
même c'était quand même un des jeux les
plus violents avant la sortie de mortal
kombat qui a eu lieu deux ans plus tard
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé sur sur internet une vidéo
d'un mec qui fasse le niveau en collant
le bon endroit il y en a plus il y en a
plus et reste pas coincé comme un con
sors de là et bim prince l'interface
kaunas de mega drive c'est qu'il pas
trop en maintenant la sécu pas trop
c'est vraiment trop con oh là là encore
des géants bol et cette fois je vais
essayer d'arriver directement au contact
je saute et et va te faire [ __ ]
[ __ ] web alors là j'ai un problème là
voyez les deux géants là ils peuvent pas
avancer
demandez pas pourquoi je sais pas sauf
que là bas ils sont juste devant le
piège dont ben voila je suis bloqué je
peux pas l'approcher et voilà dans le
public
ford stobart ford sodomie ouest bon cela
dit je dois quand même avouer que le
coût des potions corps ramassés qui
donnent différents résultats selon la
combinaison est vraiment pas mal
du coup j'avais prévu le truc je sais
que mes quatre portions blanche on peut
sauter le level donc je le fais
le dernier boss et simplement infaisable
il balance place de rayons de merle
devant lui vous ne pouvez pas sauter au
dessus vous ne pouvez pas vous approcher
c'est quasiment impossible
mais bon apparemment il existe une
tactique qui consiste à lui foncer
dessus à le tuer derrière le mur avant
qu'il n'apparaisse dans l'écran il faut
prendre une potion de boucliers et en
avant guingamp
voilà je le trouve derrière le mur est
allé en alors voilà c'est quoi ce bruit
qu'on propose c'est quoi ce bruit sans
déconner
on dirait que ma megadrive a explosé
peut-être que personne n'est censé finir
le jeu peut-être qu'il va y avoir une
fissure dans le continuum espace temps
si je tue le vase
ah ah
maintenant c'est fini en fait de lombez
enfin le bruit c'était juste pour
signaler que le boss allait mourir
c'est vraiment une idée à la con parce
que franchement ça fait flipper quoi
zenagui musclor se marièrent et eurent
plein d'enfants buffet à les eaux ouais
voilà c'est fini bon bah on a un écran
de faim de merde mais bon ça on s'y
attendait un peu à jour d'hier au
passage continue à me suggérer des jeux
dans vous voudriez vous vengez ça me
fait toujours plaisir de souffrir des
heures derrière ma télé pour vous plus
qu'à rentrer le nom pour le score et
voilà bon maintenant si vous voulez bien
m'excuser j'ai une dernière chose à
faire
[Musique]